the 46th president of the united states
joe biden
[Applause]
ah we just realized i should have had a
mask on and then ripped it off as we
started the show because that would have
been as bananas absurd as what you just
saw from the elderly man pretending to
be president of course that was last
week's appearance on the jimmy kimmel
comedy program
and biden you know he puts on the mask
just to pretend to take it off and
that's all nonsense i'm dave rubin this
is the reuben report it is monday june
13th 2022 happy birthday to my buddy
harry who i've been sparring with on the
basketball court and over video games
and politically for about 40 years now
uh we are live streaming on rumble
youtube and blaze tv of course and uh
we're going to shift direction a little
bit today because something happened
last week that i actually did not cover
because i wanted to wait to find out a
little bit uh more information and then
we now have some more information so we
thought okay we can give this thing
a deep dive but there was an
assassination attempt on supreme court
justice brett kavanaugh's life of uh
fortunately it was an attempt and not a
successful attempt
but the media
sort of
shenanigans around it either not talking
about it or confusing the issues about
it or sort of excusing it uh i think
gives you some real insight and not only
to where the media is at at the moment
but where the democrats are at at the
moment and then there's been some
pushback i sense that the young people
are getting red pilled and real fast so
that's what we're going to be doing
today quick reminder everybody i will be
at the miami improv on july 14th you can
get tickets at daverubin.com
events there are also vip seats
available if you'd like to give me the
one second hug
and that will be the last show on the
big tour the tour is over the last show
was actually in orlando with ron
desantis about a week ago but we decided
to just ask
one more in my adopted hometown of miami
uh before we get to the rest of it i
want to talk to you guys about real
estate agents i trust you know buying or
selling a home is already one of the
most stressful things you can do and it
can be 10 times worse if you're not
working with the right agent generally
speaking our homes are our biggest
investment that's a lot of
responsibility and you need an agent who
can take that seriously that's why i
recommend real estate agents i trust
they work with only the best agents in
every market they do their homework
talking to an agent before inviting them
to join their network and here's a big
one they only work with full-time pros
no part-time or inexperienced agents
their teams make the intro and then
follow you through the buying or selling
process to make sure that you're
satisfied the agents they work with have
long track records and are the best
sellers in their field they're part of
this audience they share your values and
they're almost anywhere you want to go
the process is simple just go to
realestateagentsidetrust.com today and
provide them with some basic info their
team will contact you to make an
introduction to their preferred agent in
your town and now back to me
okay so this was a serious event and as
i said i did not want to just jump in
and cover it without having a little bit
more info we have a little bit more info
now uh but there was an assassination
attempt on
the life of supreme court justice brett
kavanaugh
fox did play
some of the audio from the 911 call
all right breaking right now we have
just received the 911 call from the man
charged with attempted murder against
supreme court justice brett kavanaugh
the college from wednesday morning
when 26 year old nicholas roski spills
the details of his plan to a dispatcher
and he said you came from california do
you know someone down here
brett kavanaugh
you said red like the color
brett rex the supreme court justice
okay and you came along
correct
okay
and what were you
coming in there just to hurt yourself
and him or what was going to happen
correct
okay so there you have it laid out
pretty cleanly the kid in essence who
was going to do this saying exactly what
he was going to do
on tape now you may not have heard about
this i'm guessing actually if
you watch mainstream media although then
what are you doing here watching this
but if you know someone that watches
mainstream media they may not have heard
about this thing because mainstream
media is basically
ignoring it and my favorite slow-motion
conservative that's what i'm going to
call him for now on slow motion
conservative bill maher he actually did
cover it this past friday and one of the
things that bill maher does quite well
is basically two years after everything
that conservatives have been saying he
usually says it when it's safe to do so
and then everyone applauds him as the
last sane liberal
okay you know my feelings on that uh but
he actually took the new york times to
task for not covering it the point is i
think your point and i the point i would
agree with is
the new york times buried this yeah it
was like anything below the fold if this
had been a liberal supreme court justice
that someone came to kill
it would have been on the it would have
been on the front page and that's what's
so disappointing about a paper like the
new york times
because they just wear their bias on
their sleeves and they if it's not part
of something that feeds our narrative
[ __ ] it
all right
credit where credit is due yes that's
right the new york times sucks the new
york times lies about everything the new
york times covers certain things that if
it helps the liberal agenda and doesn't
cover certain things if it helps the
conservative agenda the new york times
is propaganda the new york times is all
in for the democrats which are the same
people that bill maher supports so this
is not an attack on bill maher this is
my usual bill hey if i had a red pill in
my hand i would throw it at the screen
right now let's get some red jelly beans
around here and start doing that okay so
i will give bill credit
for that
i wonder if he will sort of grab the
sort of holistic version of this which
is that the entire machine
is doing exactly what he's talking about
and that he's sort of part of it but if
you want proof on how the media covers
or does not cover
certain things here's a tweet from steve
guest and this is about what the sunday
shows did related to this brett
kavanaugh assassination attempt how the
sunday shows cover the attempted
assassination of supreme court justice
brett kavanaugh via tbis numbers of
mentions of kavanaugh abc's this week
this is their big sunday show zero nbc's
meet the press this is their big sunday
show
zero cbs is face the nation
zero cnn state of the union
zero fox news sunday they did cover it
um so you see what's going on there and
i know you guys get it this gets to the
sort of split in the worlds that we live
in you if you pay attention to certain
media you know actually what's going on
you know that there was a violent threat
potentially a legitimate violent threat
admitted by the guy who's going to do it
against a bret against the supreme court
justice
and if you watch certain things you
don't even know that that happened you
also may not realize that there are
plenty of democrats who have been
threatening this sort of thing for a
long time we always get the meme that
the republicans are mean and the
republicans are always threatening
democracy on the far right and the
alt-right and blah blah blah but
actually there is an awful lot of video
evidence and we've got the videotape
good work there today connor of here's
uh well we just had to pick one today we
well we got a couple but we'll start
with this one here's chuck schumer
threatening kavanaugh taking away
fundamental rights i want to tell you
gorsuch i want to tell you kavanaugh you
have released the whirlwind
and you
will pay
the price
you have released the whirlwind
and you will pay the price i think we
had a little audio freak out there but
that's what uh chuck schumer said you
have released the whirlwind gorsuch you
have released the whirlwind kavanagh and
you will pay the price now i'm not
saying that's a direct call to violence
they they dance around things in a
certain way they use words in a way that
you can't quite tell but we do know that
if that had been ted cruz or rand paul
saying something like that about ruth
bader ginsburg
of course of course everyone would be
saying this is an insurrection they are
calling for violence etc etc we do know
about the guy who was a huge bernie
supporter who shot up the congressional
softball game and nearly killed steve
scalise
amongst uh you know shooting a bunch of
other people over there and everything
else okay uh you also might remember
laurie lightfoot and i we should put it
we we should have just a general scare
warning i know we have our nonsense
warning we should have a scare warning
when we're going to show some of the
lori lightfoot remember this one from
lori lightfoot this is about two weeks
ago to my friends in the
lgbtq plus community the supreme court
is coming for us next this moment has to
be a call
to arms now call to arms seems like that
means pick up your arms and do something
about it that actually would be a
violation of the law because you're not
allowed to violently threaten people as
it seems that she is doing now again if
trump did that impeach ted cruz does
that bad guy democrats do it they're
somehow good guys here's lori lightfoot
defending her uh call to arms
will you
recall rescind your violent tweet
to uh call to arms
let him talk
the more he talks the more stupid he
sounds please will you rescind your call
to arms tweet
in the light of the mass shooting in
downtown chicago so as stupid as you
think that may be somehow the
the call to arms a call to action that i
issued in the context of the supreme
court's decision to overturn roe v wade
and basically turn back the clock 50
years time where women are not going to
be able to be in control of their other
bodies no sir i will not i will not
stand down i will not retreat because
women in this country are not going to
stand for some unelected body to tell us
that we don't have the right to control
the circumstances
in which we uh produce our children
all right clown ridiculous people
applauding for her um she completely
misses the point there that which is
that she uh specifically said call to
arms that is those are her specific
words but uh we're 50 years of rights
okay blah blah blah uh we pulled up the
numbers from this past weekend she is
the mayor of chicago 10 people were shot
dead in chicago this past weekend 62
were shot
62 were shot generally when you're
shooting somebody you're trying to kill
them so
those are 62 counts of attempted murder
you will not hear about that on cnn
obviously you will not hear about that
on nbc or anywhere else in almost every
case it's a black man shooting another
black man i don't really care about the
races of any of these things but again
they only cover certain things and not
others ten people
killed in chicago this past weekend uh
but it's not just
that they instigate this stuff with
their words that get as close as
possible to direct threats so you have
lightfoot call to arms you have uh
kavanaugh or we have chuck schumer you
know getting their faces blah blah blah
uh here's nancy pelosi just in the last
couple days completely dismissing the
threat the very obvious and real threat
that kavanaugh was under madam speaker
how can you say that the justices are
protected when there was an attempt on
justice kavanaugh's life
you said the justices are protected but
there was an attempt on justice
kavanaugh's life
[Music]
but this is about security for the
justices and armed man showed up near
justice kavanaugh's house to try to
we're working together on the bill that
the senate will be able to
approve of
because that's what we can pass whatever
we wanted we wanted to be able to pass
the senate so i don't know what you're
talking about because of what we haven't
seen what the debate is and not debate
but what the language is that there will
be a bill but nobody is in danger over
the weekend because
of our not having a bill
okay i know the audio was a little low
there so the key line is the justices
are protected nobody is in danger now we
know that there have been protests
outside of brett kavanaugh's house for a
couple weeks after the roe v wade leak
we know that plenty of democrats maxine
waters you guys have seen those videos
get in their faces give them no peace
all of those things but a guy who
literally is saying he was there to harm
the
justice of the supreme court
and then harm himself uh he admitted it
on tape like we all get that and she's
completely dismissing it well congress
then actually tried to do something they
tried to actually pass uh basically an
emergency bill to up the security nancy
pelosi killed it that's what this press
conference there was in reference to she
killed it and of course uh one of her uh
well i was going to say good friends but
i don't think they really like each
other aoc was very happy about killing
that as well
now i wake up this morning and i start
to hear murmurs that there's going to be
an attempt to pass the supreme court
supplemental protection bill
the day after gun safety legislation for
schools and kids and people
is stalled
oh so we can pass protections for us
and and here easily right but we can't
pass protections for everyday people i
think
not
just the dismissive way and the
condescending way and the smug way that
she talks and the camera angles and all
of those things it's just
right it's just awful but okay so
there's some debate we can have some
honest debate about gun safety
legislation you know my feelings on it
but more laws are not going to solve
this we have a much deeper problem than
more laws and all that the reason i
showed you that video though was because
if you really understand the way aoc
thinks what she's saying is she's not
saying that we shouldn't pass this
supreme court
this defense of supreme court justices
that there's not more we can do we can
have this supplemental bill to make sure
that they're safe she's not saying we
shouldn't do that she's saying because i
didn't get what i want we are not going
to ensure the safety of the supreme
court justices think how profoundly evil
that is but it goes right to the heart
of everything that progressives article
is certainly right to the heart of
everything that aoc is she
if she does not get what she wants she
wants to see the world burn or supreme
court justices get threatened or
potentially even murdered that seems
fairly obvious i don't think that's an
overstep if i don't get what i want i
did not get the bill that i want
because she's not saying that the bill
about the supreme court justices and
their defense she's not saying it's no
good she's just saying i'm not going to
do it because i didn't get what i want
well we've got more from aoc and i
apologize in advance but this is
actually super interesting she went on
cnn this weekend and uh dana bash
loved that name dana bash cause watching
cnn it's like being bashed in the head
dana bash asked her if she was going to
support biden in 2024 i just want to ask
about president biden he is saying he's
going to run again in 2024 will you
support him
you know if the president chooses uh to
run again in 2024 i mean first of all
i'm focused on winning this majority
right now uh and preserving a majority
this year in 2022 so we'll cross that
bridge when we get to it but um but i
think if if the president has a vision
and that's something certainly we're all
willing to entertain and examine when
when the time comes
that's not a yes
yeah you know i think we should
endorse when we get to it but i i
believe that the president has been
doing a very good job uh so far and um
you know should he run again i think
that
i you know i think it's it's
we'll take a look at it
right now we need to focus on winning a
majority instead of a presidential
election
man one of the people that like examines
body language and everything would have
a field day with that the way she's
shaking her no is she saying yes where
she laughs all of those things but
there's a few interesting things about
what happens right there now first off
remember when when they handed biden
when they made all the backdoor deals
and they handed byte in the nomination
which is exactly what they did right
let's not pretend that it was anything
other than that they all the competition
dropped out on super tuesday they
promised gayp at a job they they did all
of those things right it's just obvious
the machine wanted biden he was the the
easiest one that they could let in okay
so be it uh but when they did that what
the mainstream media and what what most
of my somewhat sane liberal friends or
what most centrists said was biden would
not be the crazy leftist that was the
whole idea of the biden campaign he's
not the socialist lunatic bernie he's
not a woke crazy person he's an old
democrat and things will get back to old
democrat ways it'll be sort of like a
bill clinton kind of thing you know he's
just joe biden he's sort of nothing but
it's nothing's better than the
socialists well biden has governed like
a far left lunatic now obviously biden
is not in charge who's in charge i'm not
quite sure i'm pretty sure it was barack
obama in easter bunny outfit a couple
weeks ago
but
he has governed as a woke leftist he has
tried to destroy the economy inflation
gas prices disastrous withdrawal in
afghanistan we can go through all of the
things right you know all of the things
try to buy a couch see what happens i
tried to literally
i tried to buy a stool yesterday an
outdoor stool for a bar and i bought it
uh the same exact stool that i was
buying uh
that i bought last year was uh 79
dollars it's now 139 that tells you
everything anyway the biden thing's a
disaster but what aoc is saying there is
really what's she saying the subtext is
even though he's given us everything we
want basically yes he didn't get rid of
uh you know college he didn't blow away
college loans and all that kind of thing
but he's pretty much done everything as
a crazy leftist but he's not good enough
for us and i guarantee you mark my words
right now
one of you write this down but dave
rubin said it the thing that comes after
biden in the democrat party is going to
be so much worse because in some ways he
was the last line of of he was the last
line of relative sanity with these
people it hasn't acted as sanity but it
was the last moment that democrats would
pretend to be sane the next thing that
comes after him which will be pushed in
by aoc when she stabs biden in the back
and they get rid of you know even though
pelosi's bananas left us now and schumer
these people who weren't their whole
careers like completely insane when they
stab all of them then they will finally
burst forth and be what they are
remember they pretended to be democrat
socialists for years they don't even say
that anymore they say that they are
socialists now there is a major
socialist movement in this country and
they have plenty of blue check twitter
accounts on our capitalist twitter um
but it's interesting because she's
basically saying it she's saying in a
weird way what we know to be true which
is that they're going to destroy biden i
don't even know that biden is going to
make it right i mean they should have
25th amendment him already the guy
cognitively obviously is not there we
all know all of these things and now
let's shift to what biden is doing
because he knows he's sort of on
borrowed time but every now and again he
has to pretend that he's really he's
really tough so first off uh he did not
say anything about the brett kavanaugh
situation he's been questioned many
times by the media they you know usually
they just rush the media out um but he
did not say anything about it at all
here's a generic one from biden just
about what he wants to do to his uh
political opponents you know
i have to admit to you
a lot of us elected officials have been
in office for a while
every once in a while something you
learn makes you viscerally angry
like if you had the person in front of
you'd want to pop them
no i really mean it
oh no i really mean it i'd want to pop
them now that's interesting considering
all the gun violence we've had for a
while popham now he was going like this
so i think he meant punch him
but uh he wants to punch his political
opponents or maybe pop them that's what
joe biden wants to do and no i really
mean it no i really mean it it's not one
of the usual nonsensical things that i
say i really want to punch or shoot
these people
that's joe biden but he basically spent
his weekend covering his butt for all of
the bad stuff that we see out there
inflation gas supply chain all of the
rest of it uh jackie toeitz on twitter
had some interesting info on what's
going on with the economy right now
inflation just hit a new 40-year high
the overall cpi is up 8.6 since last
year gas is up almost 49
fuel 106
meat poultry and fish 13
milk 16 eggs 32 percent coffee 15
used cars 16 airline fare 38
real average
hourly earnings down
3
so the thing is a freaking
disaster and i would argue this is the
greatest gift that he could hand aoc
because by governing so
completely incompetently
it will fuel their base to say oh see we
had sort of this not fully woke
progressive this old guy and he had
something to do with obama and whatever
but look he wrecked everything so we
need someone even more radical and
someone even more into socialism and
someone more into big government so she
is going to stab you joe i'm not here to
do you any favors but if any of your
people are watching this the
progressives are coming to destroy you
fool
um
now uh there's more from joe's trip to
la that that video we just showed you
that was in los angeles the dystopian
nightmare where i used to live with los
angeles i will put five dollars in the
jar to kick somebody out of florida and
send them to california that's the new
plan with this money uh they asked biden
what he's doing about uh all of these
problems and you're not gonna believe it
but he found somebody else to blame well
he's labored from forehead to the tip of
his toes he used to run the laborers out
union look folks
today i'd like to speak about my top
economic priority
fighting inflation
i understand americans are anxious and
the anxious a good reason
i was raised in a household when the
price of gasoline rose precipitously it
was the discussion at the table it made
a difference when food prices went up
but we've never seen anything like
putin's tax on both food and gas
all right so first usually you know you
get the rambling right you just get the
little litter what's he saying you don't
really know and then of course it has
nothing to do with printing all of the
money it has nothing to do with all of
their bad economic policies this is
putin's price act now let's pretend for
a second that there's some legitimacy to
that that there is this war between
russia and ukraine and that because of
the resources and the oil and all of
those things that we live in this global
world now and when wars break out
especially with a big country that has a
lot of resources like russia that it can
affect the economies of other countries
let's say that's roughly true because
there's obviously some truth to that
isn't it the job
of the presidents and the prime
ministers of the other countries to
figure out how to compensate for that
like if one guy if if putin can invade
ukraine and know that he can disrupt the
entire world economy wouldn't it be your
job as the president of another country
say the united states of america to have
some firewalls in place to have some
policies perhaps in place
that would stop uh our economy from
tanking during that
i think that's what it would be but
that's not exactly what he's doing here
uh also he's just sort of incoherently
saying that exxon mobil is marking up
their prices for profit i don't know
that that's even true but also i
wouldn't i don't blame oil companies for
making money i don't blame anyone for
making money
maybe i guess there's some level of some
argument okay maybe they're making too
much money right now or something like
that i'm not even sure that that's
actually a legit argument but again that
that's not why the economy is tanking
it's tanking because you guys are
borrowing like crazy people you're
spending like crazy people and you're
printing money like crazy people that's
really the problem it isn't just that
when uh putin goes into ukraine that
exxon is like now we'll stick it to the
people like that's just not how it works
they're making money exxon's making
money because their stock is going up
but okay let's move on uh here is uh
we're going to keep me on the screen for
this one uh here's biden with some more
wizardry
we're going to make sure that everybody
knows exxon's prophecy why don't you
tell them what exxon's profits were this
year this quarter
exxon made more money than god this year
wow
god better get a new account exxon made
more money than god
good god this man's an idiot this man is
an absolute idiot well what else did he
do
this past weekend he spent some time
with the evil dictator of the north
justin trudeau and uh well
look at this
thank you
well thank you all very much
thank you thank you get out of here joe
biden has dementia he has old person
syndrome he doesn't know what he's doing
we can't let him answer questions and
justin trudeau is an evil freak okay you
gotta go you gotta go and then they just
sit there i mean we could have played
more of that it's just so uncomfortable
and the aides yelling get out of the
room no questions it's just absolutely
ridiculous press was only even allowed
in the room for four minutes uh but
i don't want to just make this about joe
biden because justin trudeau you know my
feelings about justin trudeau and as
jordan peterson says justin trudeau
fundamentally cannot say anything true
he is the worst sort of authoritarian i
wear a nice suit i have a nice haircut
oh look at my pink socks i love the
lgbtq lmnob people who will gladly use
the government to take you
out and if you don't believe me listen
to this zinger
and there are debates and we have a
culture where the difference is guns can
be used for hunting or for sport
shooting in canada and there's lots of
gun owners and they're mostly lost
respecting and law abiding
but you can't use a gun for
self-protection in canada that's not a
right that you have in the constitution
or anywhere else if you try and buy a
gun and say it's for self-protection no
you don't get that you get it for
hunting you can get it for sport
shooting take it to the range no problem
as long as you go through our rigorous
background checks but there's a
difference around the culture and one of
the things that we're seeing with the
debate in the states is you get more and
more of the american style you know
right to carry self-defense arguments
filtering up through through the uh you
know the usual more right-wing
communications channels yeah i would
like to say as a leader of the
right-wing communications channels thank
god
for the constitution of the united
states thank god for the bill of rights
thank god for the second amendment thank
god for all of the people who proudly
defend it thank god for those ideas that
are still percolating to our north so
the average canadian can realize that
that guy wants all the guns and wants to
be able to make sure you can't protest
or shut down your bank account or
everything else but how insane you can't
use a gun for self-protection
you can't according to him in canada you
can't so someone can break into your
house and maybe you have a gun there
because you hunt elk or deer up in
canada right you can't use that gun to
defend yourself the state should only
have guns that's the way he wants it but
now because you know i like to bring
these things around and give you some
hope there is something happening
because it's not just aoc that is
turning unbidet and youth culture is
turning on biden and the democrats and
and trudeau and all these things young
people are waking up which of course is
always why the threat of censorship just
sits there because the more people wake
up the more they have to clamp down on
people who are thinking freely who are
thinking things through for themselves
who are you know flickering that that
light the neurons are firing again
they're swallowing that red pill so you
know this jake paul guy he's got 20
million subs on youtube he's got 4.3
million followers on twitter he's huge
for the young people i'm not exactly
sure what he does he does like prank
videos and he occasionally fights people
or something
he's big the point is it doesn't matter
whether i know anything about the guy or
not he's big with the kids well he
tweeted this out just in the last day or
two biden accomplishments highest gas
prices worst inflation plummeting crypto
prices highest rent prices ever created
new incomprehensible language
if you're reading this and voted for
biden and you still don't regret it then
you are the american problem that got
122
000
likes okay
this is big it doesn't matter if you
watching this know this guy or not he's
big within young people the fact that
young people are now waking up to this
insanity realizing that things were
pretty good
under trump they were damn good under
trump uh he
this is the point this guy was he was a
holly he was like a disney actor right
is that where that's what started this
guy like something is actually
happening here but what are they gonna
have to do now you know where i'm going
with this when people start waking up
what do they have to do they have to
censor you or there's the other option
that they have which is scare the flying
bejesus out of you and what might the
gop do or not do with their newly
claimed power
so the january 6
commission would cease to exist
the findings will be completely
suppressed and will not be
admitted into any for further
investigations while the gop uh will be
in power uh they would impr um they
would um impeach president biden um as
quickly as possible and they will
continue to continue to find ways uh to
impeach him going forward it would also
embolden
republicans and the far right and white
nationalists across the country to begin
to believe that it is their time to not
just take power in the house but the
senate the white house and state houses
across the country and we got to
understand that this is a group that has
been radicalized by the great
replacement myth and many other things
and have been pushing for violence and
pushing for even civil war
you see what they're gonna do they're
telling you what they're gonna do and
when people tell you what they're gonna
do when people tell you what they really
think you should believe them so they're
prepping their own audience because
they're going if we can't censor
everybody and we are going to get
crushed in the midterms which is what it
looks like we better get everyone as
fearful as possible because the white
nationalists might launch a civil war
yeah
it's such crazy nonsense by the way that
guy
that guy he's a he's a new york
congressman that's not just one of their
generic like msnbc contributor lunatics
he's a new york congressman and if the
republicans retake congress they're
going to impeach biden well they might
and he probably should be impeached
because he doesn't have the mental
capacity to be president you guys also
ran two fake impeachments but that white
nationalists are coming they're coming
and the civil war is here and again guys
that's why i always say what do we do
with these people we can't turn these
people around i can't turn around the
truly
uh
kool-aid drunk people of msnbc but we
can separate from them and i don't mean
that in a violent civil war i mean that
from build new things and let them
let them have some stuff and let them
destroy themselves and we'll go on and
live better lives uh we got a cold close
for you in just a moment oh and at noon
today i will be live for the hour on the
megan kelly show on siriusxm and then
it's released as a podcast on the
youtube later today is monday which
means it is meme monday over at the
reuben report locals community here's
the meme that i put up today companies
on june 1st you know i'm something of a
homosexual myself and of course that's
from spider-man 2
the first time around guys for the
record michael was a little confused
there's been 87 spider-man that was
spider-man 2 with the original dr
octopus
okay there you go a couple comments from
the locals community nuclear patrick
says putin tax is the new russia hoax
yes absolutely well said
it is remember we had four years of
russia russia russia russia installed
the president russia's running the bots
blah blah blah now everything that goes
on it's still russia's fault it's still
russia's fault such drivel kathy d says
inflation will be the reason for the red
wave yeah i mean maybe more than
anything else inflation will do it i
think you can make an argument that the
critical race theory stuff and the
gender stuff in schools once they
started really really going after the
children that that woke up a lot of sort
of apolitical people right so there's
there's the general political people who
see inflation go up and they realize oh
that is connected to the policies of
these dingbats
those people might change their vote
right you're sort of this like nominal
average democrat and you're like boy you
know actually putting aside everything
else things were better a couple years
ago so this is bad that's one type of
person that can move but i think the
real person that's going to move is the
person who was just sending their kid to
school and you know now their son is a
girl and the rest of the drivel nonsense
fat dog creatives says at least mar is
seeing it any day now i think he'll wake
up yeah look again all of my criticisms
of mar even when they're a bit uh
intense
are
there they're measured in that i want
him to get there i want him to see that
when now right now bill maher you
finally maybe for the first time on your
show said that the new york times is
propaganda well it's like okay we've
been saying it for 10 years right and by
the way there were people before us that
were saying it long before that so it's
like
either get there or
we do have to call you out which is just
like oh you're just a slow motion
conservative right we should do a
segment on the show called double take
with bill maher and we'll just do things
that he said two years ago where he was
getting democrats elected and then two
years later he does the double take and
he's like oh see and it's like oh but
you're just repeating all that
conservative crazy conservative stuff
uh guys as always uh you can join us and
play along at reubenreport.locals.com
by the way we will be releasing we're
going to discuss it after uh we will be
releasing my full stand-up set from the
final show the show in orlando it's
about 40 minutes to stand up completely
unedited uh i think you will see that
comedy actually is back it's just not
coming from uh the political side of the
aisle that the mainstream media has
taught you we will be releasing the full
thing on locals uh every annual
subscriber to the
reubenreport.locals.com
community we'll get it whether you're a
subscriber now or a new subscriber i'll
have some more info on that soon uh my
full interview with uh florida governor
ron desantis is up on youtube and rumble
and of course it's been up on locals
already and finally we've got a funny
cold close for you happy monday and i'll
see you tomorrow president biden
continues to campaign for more economic
chaos
meanwhile i don't know about where you
live jesse but
in in my state the price of gas
is so high
that it would be cheaper to buy cocaine
and just run everywhere
you